- I'm Terry Crews.
A lot of people think I'm intimidating.
Well I don't tend to agree with that.
Let's prove 'em wrong.
Yo listen up!
I don't wanna interrupt.
I'm just here to prove something.
The question I have for the
day, is do I intimidate you?
I yell good things, motivational stuff.
I yell it in their face so
they know it and they feel it.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
But the world doesn't know
that I'm the most motivational,
non-intimidating brother in the world!
When I slam my hand down,
which really is just a symbol
of, you know, kind of camaraderie.
Kinda like a high-five for the workplace.
Right there!
Hey!
It's camaraderie.
Don't you ever say I'm intimidating!
Ever!
You've stopped working
and you're looking at me.
So am I intimidating to you or something?
That's the right answer, boy.
That's the right answer.
That made me happy!
The other question is
are you just saying that
because I'm standing here?
Does this intimidate you?
Does that intimidate?
Or is it this that intimidates you?
Is it, you know, the fact that
I've been married 27 years
with five kids and I'm a grandpa?
That's what I'm talking about!
I don't intimidate nobody!
Security!
I see you running around
here securing stuff.
How you doing, man?
I'm here to prove that I
don't intimidate people.
You know shout it man, tell 'em.
Tell 'em.
No say it, say it, say it
for real, like get on 'em!
You heard it from the man
who will be the first one to kick me out
if I was intimidating
any of the workers here.
As you can see, nobody was intimidated.
So if you ever talk that (bleep) again,
you can just shut the (bleep) up!
Whatcha doing?
Do I intimidate you at all?
I stand corrected.